aaron rodgers has been in all sorts of
hot water because it turns out that he
in fact was not vaccinated for covet 19.
now the rule in the nfl was that you
were supposed to get vaccinated for
covent 19. i'm not sure what sort of
evidence he provided to the green bay
packers that he was vaccinated so that
he was not suspended or prevented
from actually going out on the field but
then he actually got coveted 19. now
aaron rodgers is one of the healthiest
people on planet earth right aaron
rodgers is an nfl quarterback he's in
his 30s this is not somebody who has to
worry significantly about dying from
covid 19. but apparently
the rest of the world has to go nuts
over this this is very very bad now
remember everybody else presumably in
that locker room unless they are lying
is vaccinated which means they are safe
from aaron rodgers it doesn't matter
everybody has decided to go nuts on
aaron rodgers how dare aaron rodgers not
backed how dare he not back among the
world's healthiest human beings nearly
all of whom are vaccinated apparently
now back in august rogers had said that
he was immunized it was unclear exactly
what he meant by immunize had he already
had coved or something so he was on a
show called the pat mcafee show
and uh he said that he was in the
crosshairs of the woke mob right now
there's certainly truth to this the
amount of ink and outrage that's being
spilled over aaron rodgers is so much
greater than the amount of outrage
spilled over that las vegas raiders
player who recently murdered some
he recently allegedly killed somebody by
hitting them with a card 156 miles an
hour while drunk
my dad was out of the news in like one
second he was dropped by the team but
the team put out like kind of attempted
statement about it did it occasion any
sort of national conversation about
behavior of of various football players
and the levels of irresponsibility of of
the football players generally no but
aaron rodgers we get
a week of coverage about how aaron
rodgers is the apotheosis of evil
i realize i'm in the crosshairs of the
woke mob right now so before my final
nail gets put in my cancel culture
casket
i think i'd like to set the record
straight on so many of the uh blatant
lies that are out there about myself
right now when trump
in 2020 was championing these
uh vaccines that were coming so quick
what did the left say and i'm talking
about every member of the left don't
trust the vaccine don't get the vaccine
you're going to die from the vaccine
and then what happened biden wins and
everything flips shouldn't that
initially give you a little bit of pause
and go hold on a second isn't this about
health
and not about like politics
um
he is not totally wrong on that now i'm
a big fan of the vaccines i think he's
wrong about the vaccines and the health
effects of the vaccines but he is not
wrong to have institutional mistrust of
an entire media that suggested that the
vaccines would not be developed in time
and were super bad when trump developed
them but as soon as biden was elected
suddenly the vaccines became the cure
apparently according to nfl insider ian
rappaport he said that rogers has been
following nfl coven 19 guidelines for
unvaccinated players which require daily
testing even on off days and the wearing
of protective masks indoors but rapid
says the nfl is going to investigate if
the protocols have been strictly
implemented because rogers had been
spotted not wearing a mask during some
indoor press conferences with reporters
at lambeau
well then so it turns out that they have
been doing daily testing so it's not
like he was positive in just hanging
around people
it turns out they've been testing like
pretty much
all the time
so was he putting other people at risk
and if the idea is that he had to wear a
mask was not to put other people at risk
vaccinated people past this too
rapoport said he has in his words been
immunized which is he sought a holistic
or homeopathic treatment to try and
raise his antibody levels and then went
to the nfl and their joint doctors to
get what is essentially an exemption he
tried to get them to say okay because
where your antibody levels are you're
allowed to say you're vaccinated the nfl
nflpa and joint doctors did not allow
that so he was officially ruled to be
unvaccinated that's the reality that's
why aaron rodgers despite sort of
leading the public to believe he's
vaccinated
his official status is he did not
receive the covet 19 vaccination the nfl
is reviewing the situation
apparently they can find him
so
if he was gathered outside of team
facilities or team traveling groups of
more than three that could result in the
five about 15 grand
attending an indoor nightclub or indoor
bar of more than 15 people unless you
are unv unless you are vaccinated could
carry a fine of like 15 grand and if you
didn't submit testing results that's 50
grand
so
why i have a question why is this like
the world's biggest deal
really why is this the world's biggest
deal first of all on virtually all other
issues we sort of assume that your
health is your business now
we are dealing with the world's youngest
and healthiest population here you're
dealing with a group of people who again
probably are largely vast at this point
so everyone in that locker room has had
the opportunity to get facts why are we
calling this guy like an insane person
why are we going after him like he's a
crazy person we'll get back to more on
aaron rodgers in just one second first
when we started daily wire we wanted to
make sure that we knew down to the very
marrow of our company's bones how
everything worked
we're focused in on our marketing we're
focused in on data analytics well you
should be able to do the same sort of
thing and this is what giant partners
does it's time to position your company
as an industry leader create buzz
attract new customers generate
consistent revenue giant partners is
here to help you do it giant partners
they're america's number one data-driven
marketing agency giant partners operates
in the business to business space
offering a variety of business marketing
solutions like database marketing brand
development web design seo lead
generation digital marketing services as
well as the ad placement that's just to
name some of what they do whether you
own a small family business or handle
millions of dollars in revenue every
year giant partners can help you get to
that next level their marketing
strategies are research driven they're
equipped with 20 years of data
experience don't take my word for it
their largest customers include bmw
nationwide ohio state university 3m and
ethan allen so head on over to
giantpartners.com get your business set
up today
members of the media have it extremely
backwards what they are saying they say
things like well look at colin
kaepernick that guy was run out of
football for his perspective no he was
running out of football because he was a
crappy quarterback and aaron rodgers is
an mvp if colin kaepernick had been an
mvp he could have mouthed off as much as
he wanted and he would still be under
center
he was not nearly as good as aaron
rodgers is end of story
the real question is why aaron rodgers
occasions this sort of outrage but colin
kaepernick wearing socks that had cops
projected as pigs on them
instead earned him million-dollar
contracts for his point of view
that's the part that's kind of shocking
and meanwhile big bird is pushing the
vacs at this point now this is not rare
sesame street has done this before if
you go back to 1972 big bird was pushing
the measles back the difference of
course is that measles vaccines were had
been in wide use for a decade or more by
the time this happened and were
mandatory in most schools across the
united states here is big bird circa
1972 pushing vaccination
well there's all kinds of people and
they're all in a line and they don't
look like they're buying candy and
there's a sign that says
don't wait
vaccinate you know josh
okay so that was back in 1972 fast
forward about 50 years and big bird
apparently has undergone some sort of
testosterone therapy because his voice
therapy because his voice is super duper
different and now he's talking with
sanjay gupta about why he should get the
copy 19 vaccine now remember there's a
bit of a difference the measles vaccines
have been widely tried by the early 70s
they're mandatory at nearly every school
the covet 19 vaccines are not mandatory
for school kids anywhere except for
maybe san francisco and the amount of
data on them for small kids is still
fairly minimal which is why a lot of
people are in wait and see mode
also the big question here is if you are
a publicly funded entity
shouldn't you be directing your
your instructions for a voluntary
vaccine
at the parents rather than the kids
and the parents are the ones who are in
charge of the health are they not not
the public officials anyway here is a
newly butched up big bird making the
case for the coveted vaccine with sanjay
gupta who presumably was also going to
talk to him about the evils of horsty
warmer or something
uh i have one more question oh sure
what's that well uh
i'm a little scared to get the shot
because i don't like needles
will it hurt oh it's okay to be scared
and to have some of those big feelings
big bird can i tell you something i'm a
grown-up and i don't really like needles
either in fact even as an adult i don't
like to look when the doctor puts that
shot in my arm it was like well i've
been working out so it's fine
at least an octave that's kind of
amazing just like on an aesthetic level
wouldn't you get somebody who can
imitate big bird's original voice when i
first heard this clip of big bird i'll
be honest with you i haven't had any
correspondence with the big bird in
quite a while last time i was probably
seven years old i'm now 37 years old the
last i remembered big bird his voice was
more like the 1972 big bird and then
they hired somebody who apparently had
been smoking a pack of cigarettes every
day he's like i'm here to take the kova
vaccine
okay
okay big bird
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed